uh my name is guy royce i'm a developer
advocate at redis labs
so what the heck is web assembly
that's probably the first question you
would ask right what's web assembly
uh well uh in in true spongebob fashion
i asked my computer wife karen that'd be
the spongebob karen not the internet
karen
um and she told me that it was 50 web
and 50
assembly which is uh kind of funny not
really but it's
it's kind of a weak joke but it's also
kind of true right
uh because it is assembly language for
the web browser
um it's also kind of not true because
it's moving beyond the web to uh command
line tools
and uh it's not actually assembly it's
byte code assembly is a language that
renders down the machine code or by code
so
it's both true and false at the same
time but more than anything
webassembly is a solution to a problem
like any good technology right
and that problem is javascript what the
hell javascript
i mean look at i mean okay so before i
sit here and diss javascript i want to
say that
i'm a fan of javascript i run the
columbus javascript user group
i like javascript i like it unironically
but it's got some really
challenged corners right uh looking at
some of these examples uh
number.min value is greater than zero
wow i wish that was true of my bank
account
right uh my favorite here is parseint
fire truck
this is actually a very reasonable
statement fire truck it turns out
it's not a number and so that's what it
returns if you say parson
fire truck comma 16 well then that's 15
which is not a fire truck
what's going on here of course is that
uh when you say commas 16 for parson
you're
you're saying uh make this hex-based
make this a this is a hexadecimal number
so you know javascript beautifully goes
and starts parsing the string fire truck
finds the digit f which is 15 finds the
digit i
which is not a number and so it says oh
i'll just stop here and
15 is good um you might also be
wondering uh why i
chose the word fire truck here and it's
because um
my uh my son my oldest son who's 19 now
but at the time he's about six or seven
he tells me this joke he says dad i'm
thinking of a word and it starts with
the
letter f and it ends in uck
and he's kind of smiling and he's like
fire truck
so so i thought that was a fun example
right
uh it's not totally not a passive way of
me explaining my frustration with
javascript sometimes
so the nice thing about javascript
though is if you don't like it
you can pick a different language as
long as it's javascript
now i i know there's things like
typescript and
there's typescript um and you've got
these
these tools that will transpile
javascript
non-javascript languages into javascript
but that's not really
picking another language because it's
still javascript under the covers
um in the previous talk mike was kind of
talking about how
we need to compile that javascript he's
right compiling is what we want
we don't want to transpile i think the
fact that we made up a word
made up the word transpile to describe
what we're doing when we're converting
you know es6 javascript to you know you
know to
something that'll run on internet
explorer um
is a hint that we're doing something
weird
but you know but we can transpile and
use different languages we're not stuck
with javascript
although our errors often come back to
us in javascript but there's
actually kind of another flaw with
javascript aside from its weird syntax
or not weird syntax but it's uh weird
edge cases and
the lack of uh linguistic diversity that
you can have for front-end work
and that's that's it's fundamentally a
scripting language
for javascript we have to download the
javascript file and we can minify that
and that helps but they're still kind of
big
uh we have to tokenize that we gotta put
you know we gotta find all the tokens
and uh
link all the syntactical tokens in there
then we gotta take those tokens and
parse them into an abstract syntax
syntax tree and then once we have that
we can execute it
and we got to do that every time now
there is caching that happens there and
v8 does
provide as much capability as it can but
this is an expensive process
and it just affects the performance of
javascript and browsers
and so um but what if uh there was some
way
that we could compile code to run in the
browser
if we could compile code to run in the
browser we could pick whatever language
we wanted
and so we wouldn't be stuck with
javascript uh we could um
make it small and tight and compiled
into some sort of byte code
and so we wouldn't have this parsing
problem this performance issue
and that is what webassembly is
webassembly is code that has been
compiled for the browser
and uh it's kind of cool it's
um it's a virtual machine that runs in
your browser runs a webassembly byte
code
so um i thought it might be to really
kind of
make it crystal the idea behind what
webassembly is is we might want to talk
a little bit about the run-up that gets
us to webassembly yeah how did we
you know what does web assembly work
well and so i'm going to how does
webassembly do what it does how does it
fit into the bigger picture
and in order to do that i'm going to
start all the way back at the beginning
with microprocessors
so with uh microprocessors that we all
know you've got
um you know a series of bits so ones and
zeros high voltage and low voltage
that represent instructions that come in
and so an instructor might say to
move this value from you know register x
to register y
or put this value in a particular
register so we've got these instructions
that come in
and early on this is how you programmed
computers
you just wrote machine code that
represented these instructions
um and very early on just flipping
switches and hit a button and hitting a
button very very tedious
and to make that problem make
programming these microprocessors
less painful we came up with the idea of
assembly language so here i've got on
the on the left we've got
uh you know just an arbitrary address in
memory we've got the binary
representation the bits that represent
this short
machine language instruction a machine
language
uh for a 6502 microprocessor actually
this
this was the code for my first uh
machine
machine language work the first code i
ever wrote in machine language
back in the 80s we've got that those
same numbers translated hex you can see
hex
is a little easier to work with but you
still got a zero zero zero what does
that mean
but in assembly you can write a little
text document
and use mnemonics things that make it
easy for humans to understand so you see
like ldy for load y and then zero zero
for
uh the value zero so load zero into
the y register and uh and then the
assembler would go through this code
and turn it into bite for bytes you know
this symbol
means this hex code and this symbol
means this hex code so there's a
one-to-one correlation from the assembly
to the machine code and uh
that was a great innovation it made
programming much easier
but it did mean that you had to learn a
different assembly language for every
species of microprocessor
and it was also kind of hard to work
with and so we introduced higher level
languages like c
this is you know some sample c code here
it does the same thing
that that assembly code does but it's in
c and with c
we can take that code and compile it as
opposed to assembling it
and we'll get a binary that's similar to
the binary that we
you know coded in assembly and then we
can run that on our 6502 microprocessor
and
life is grand but there's a problem with
this
i write in c and i compile it for this
processor but there's a lot of
processors
uh and so i need to compile for all the
processors and sometimes i can't take
advantage of all the processors
capabilities because i want to preserve
backwards compatibility i want to make
sure my code
will run on the most number of machines
because i'm selling my software
right and so uh we solve this problem
the way that we solve all the problems
in computer science which is we added a
layer of abstraction
we added a we added a virtual
microprocessor and so instead of having
a physical microprocessor we got a
virtual microprocessor that has a
a byte code it has an assembly language
of its own
and we can compile to that byte code and
then it will in turn interpret
the code uh into something that the
microprocessor can see so here we've got
it's no longer c code it's java code and
you can tell it's java code because it's
identical
uh actually you can tell us java code
because it's got that cafe babe at the
very beginning of it
and then that java code runs on the
virtual machine and then the virtual
machine
hands off instructions to the
microprocessor in an interpreted fashion
and these can get smarter and more
sophisticated
for performance and you can actually get
faster performance out of these virtual
machines than you can
the uh the uh the physical ones because
you can optimize
you can do just in time compilation and
optimize it for exactly the specific
hardware you have
so you can crank a lot of power out of
these things it's actually pretty cool
webassembly is exactly the same idea for
the browser
so now we can take the c code or
whatever language you want
compile it to bytecode to webassembly by
code and then
create a file that all the major
browsers can
uh read and work with so that's what
webassembly is
it's this idea of a virtual
microprocessor in the browser
pretty cool i think it's cool um
so let's get into the nuts and bolts of
webassembly and see how we can actually
do this
and uh i'm going a little fast because i
want to have time for my demo
um because i kind of want to show off
that this stuff is real and you can
actually use it today
a webassembly module is literally just a
file
it's a dot wasm file specifically and i
kind of think of them as like dlls
uh if you've got a a a a windows
background at all if you did any early
windows developments
because they're basically um a bag of
functions
and so here we've got you know say a
simple calculator module that has five
functions for doing
basic mathematics for doing basic
arithmetic
and so that's all a webassembly module
is is is bytecode
in a file with a wasm extension it's
just a binary file
but that exposes these these functions
in the browser you have it becomes just
another file that you download so on the
left here we have our site css or
index.html and our app.js
and um these are sort of the you know
the classic trifecta of uh
web front-end web development you know
you get your
wonderful know wonderful site.css it
says effortless display none
um got a really basic html
uh we got some uh an app.js and then
webassembly is just another file that
the web browser can download
and we got some little code here that
shows you how that works but i got
better slides for that
the the interesting part here is the
arrows so uh
your app.js of course can interact with
your dom and manipulate it right that's
that's the essence of web apps
uh but you can also uh it can also
interact with webassembly and
webassembly can interact with it
so my javascript code on the front end
becomes something that webassembly can
talk to
and i it can talk to webassembly
now you'll notice there's not an arrow
connecting webassembly to the dom right
up here
right right up here i'm i'm arrowing i'm
pointing on the wrong screen
uh and um that's true uh webassembly
cannot talk to the dom
yet it's being worked on it's a hard
problem
but it can talk to javascript which can
talk to the dom so you can write glue
code to solve that problem
but uh this is just sort of the
ecosystem these modules live in
um to use it from javascript
uh we've got a really simple bit of code
here that includes a callback and
everything
um the the key thing here is to create a
webassembly module you call fetch
and then just the path to the file and
then you you feed that fetch call into
instantiate streaming
and that will asynchronously retrieve uh
your module
once you have the module you can just
call methods on it
uh the module has an instance the
instance has exports the exports are
where all your functions are at
and you just call them and use them like
you would any javascript function
it's actually really easy to use it once
you have one
if you want to import some functions
that web assembly webassembly can call
back against
uh then you can create this little uh
higher this little object structure up
here that has all your callback
functions in it
and pass that in when you instantiate
the webassembly module
and so that provides functions that
webassembly can then use to call back
the idea here is is this perhaps when we
call add subtract and multiply
it also calls a callback reporting the
value in addition to returning it
so that's the idea here and so that
would allow us to like log out all our
answers in addition to having code to it
it creates sort of an event model in a
way
from the webassembly side of things i'm
going to show you webassembly text
format which is
the assembly language for webassembly
and
webassembly text formats looks like this
it has a module the module declares
everything starts with a module it's the
container for everything
uh if you want to declare some functions
you just declare them using the syntax
here
func dollar add you give it a couple of
parameters if you need them
you give it a return value if you need
it these are both 32-bit integers and it
returns a 32-bit integer
and then you've got your implementation
of that function and same thing for
subtract
in other functions
to export those functions you just have
to add an export statement and
give it a string right here that then uh
you know ali it's an externally facing
alias to the internal function
so you can affect have private functions
in webassembly by not exporting them
uh to import to access that math
callback that i showed you on the
javascript side
you just use this import syntax here and
you just use those those two keywords
that were
there in that object hierarchy and you
just give it a name internal so this is
just mapping it internally
um webassembly is stack based
so it's a stack based virtual machine so
what that means is that when you call a
function
there are no intermediate variables you
just use the stack instead
so uh local.getdollara means get the
first parameter
that was passed into this function and
put it on the stack
dollar b means get the second one so now
we have two items on our stack five and
ten
when we call add add will pop those two
values off the stack because add wants
two values
if they're not there then it'll error
and then uh
it will add them together and push the
answer back onto the stack
then when we're at the end of the
function
um well then there's one islands on the
stack
that's the return value so that's that's
how these work
this is how a stack based uh assembly
language works
uh here's a slightly fancier example uh
that shows that the callbacks in action
and this is interesting because you've
got to mind you've got to be mindful of
how the stack works here so
after we uh you know i define a local
variable up here you can actually define
locals
uh and then after we add them i set that
local
and then in order to return in order to
call the callback i got to put something
on the stack for
its arguments so i get the local that i
created
and then in order to have a return value
i got to get that
again so i end up having to get that
local value a couple times
in order to return it and do the
callback so the stack's a little
clunky and weird sometimes
however you can use s expressions uh to
clean up your code and it makes your
webassembly text format look a little
more lispy
shall we say and so that's uh it's kind
of fun too
it makes it makes it actually a little
more pleasant to program it
uh there's a lot of other stuff in the
syntax here you've got shared memory
which
means it's a shared block of memory that
javascript
and webassembly can both see you've got
globals which are like shared memory but
they're just an individual value that
javascript and webassembly can again
both see
and you've got tables which are again
javascript and webassembly can both see
those
but tables are a way of doing uh like
lists of functions
so that you can uh dynamically bind
functions in languages like for
polymorphism and c plus plus and stuff
like that
so this is some other more advanced
stuff that i'm not going to go into
if you want to program webassembly in
something other than webassembly text
format which you might want to do
these are the two go-to languages that
have the deepest supports
at c and c plus and rust i think of the
two rust actually has
the better support uh rust out of the
box just install rust and you have
webassembly support it just works
uh i mean you have to do stuff but
there's nothing extra that you have to
install other than a particular target
uh there's a lot of others go out to
this link here at awesome wasm languages
i was looking at the other day and uh
cobalt was even on the list of of all
things so um
there's a lot of a lot of stuff
happening in the web assembly space
uh coming down the pike you know i've
just been showing stuff with numbers
and uh there's a reason for that and
that's because webassembly doesn't know
what a string is
and that's because how what what is a
string right what does c
mean when it says a string what does
rust mean when it says a string is that
utf-8 encoded is that you know
what's the encoding on that and so uh
one of the things that are coming down
the pike is
interface types that'll allow you to
create some common types that
webassembly modules can export and
that's uh like the browser would
understand how to make use of their
super bleeding edge there's some
polyfills that make them work
i was playing with them and then newer
code says we've turned that off for the
time being until the standard stabilizes
so it's super bleeding edge but this
will solve this problem
uh threads are i believe threads work in
firefox now i haven't looked at them
yet uh but the thing i think is
particularly interesting is wazzy
or wassi this is the webassembly systems
interface
and that allows you to do a file io and
network io
outside of the browser so if you're
doing something with a command line tool
like with a wasm time
then you could use wazi and i'm actually
going to
going to demo that along with some other
things here really quick
so excuse me let me let me grab a drink
here really quick
okay it's water but it had root beer in
it now it tastes kind of root beer like
so let's get on with the demo here so
no i didn't want to do that but that's
okay so i've got
um i've created fizzbuzz in webassembly
and i've created it three different ways
i've created in um
java for the browser uh once
in webassembly text format once in rust
and once i created a fizzbuzz that runs
on the command line
the two that run on the browser i'm
using jasmine because it's a convenient
embeddable
uh sort of um testing framework i just
had to drop some files in there you
didn't have to install anything
uh and it runs and hits uh
looks for the fizzbuzz.wasm and the rust
fizz post.wasm and test them both and i
have this up and running now so if we
bring this up
and i hit refresh you see that it does
indeed run all the test pass
now i want to prove that this is real
not vaporware so um
i am going to actually compile something
here so here here we have uh
fizzbuzz.what and so this is the code
that does fizzbuzz it returns -1 for
fizz
minus 2 for buzz and minus three for
fizzbuzz
and so um i'm not gonna go over the code
too much here but i'm gonna go and
change the constants
so for fizzbuzz i'm gonna return 30
20 and 10 instead
negative versions of those and then i'm
going to compile it using
webassembly binary toolkits
webassembly binary toolkit or wabit uh
has a tool called what to wasm
so wabbit has what the wasm which is
kind of funny um
and then i pass it my wac file so what
to wasm
fizzbuzz.what and that will spit out a
new wasm file for me
um and if we do a little ls here you'll
see that the the timestamps change to
which is my local time and if we do a
hex dump
on the fizzbuzz.wasm you'll see that
that is the entire file
it is 111 bytes that is
compact af isn't it um so i've changed
this it does different things let's see
it fail
oops wrong key combination there we go
now we now
all of them failed uh well not all of
them
but all uh almost all of them failed
and the rust one i didn't touch so it
didn't fail and
uh i can actually go out and pull these
from the uh from the console here so
let's say uh let's
m for module equal awaits and i got a
little helper function i wrote called
load wasm
um and i'll say load what slash
fizz buzz dot wasm
and then i've got a function m dot
fizzbuzz
it even auto detects it and let's pass
it like 15.
it returns minus 30. let's pass it 10.
see so that broken version is there i
can also
go out and get the rust version which
i'm actually i'm not going to show the
rust version
type in the rest version because the
path's long and complicated but you can
see that it's actually doing things
the rust version here is a lot simpler
um because it's rust and it's a higher
level language and so i'm just
doing a modulus and doing some matching
and returning it here
but if i want to build it i can
i just do uh i can do i've got a cargo
towel set up for this i can do cargo
build
slash target and then i gotta say wasm
unknown uncone
and then i want to do a release build
because that will make it about 200
bytes if i do a debug build i'll get
like one and a half megabytes because
like everything from russ will be in
there uh so that creates the new file if
i do an ls
target uh wasm 32
release we can see that we have the
fizzbuzz.wasm that is 258 bytes
if i do a hex dump you can see that
that is um yeah
i gotta get an actual file name do i you
can see that it's it's very
very short and uh that that of course
will run as well
uh the really cool thing that is um that
i think is the uh fizzbezio dot watt
and i here i have written a fully string
running
everything uh using uh uh the
sort of temporary version of webassembly
interface types
um so here we're importing something
from uh wasmtime
from wazzy unstable and a right so we
can write out to standard io
and this is actually a lot of code that
defines strings
and does the fsbos calculation and
writes new lines
and then in order to take numbers and
turn them into strings we had to
or take strings and turn up numbers turn
them into strings we had to do loops and
all kinds of crazy stuff
and all this code is out in github for
you to explore but the cool thing
is is that i can do what to asm
[Music]
fizzbuzz.io.what
and it just compiles it it just works
and so here we see that all that code is
609 bytes
and we do wasm time which is the command
line tool
this code loops from 1 to 50
and computes fizzbuzz for everything and
if it's not a number
and then it just skips it and so this is
a little command line version
of fizzbuzz so kind of cool
it's real stuff you can do real things
with it uh i think wasm time is kind of
like node.js to webassembly
that's sort of i think a proper analogy
for it so um
yeah that's pretty much what i got
here's a good little list of resources
here to check
out webassembly org github.com
webassemblies
that's the official stuff mozilla
developer network has great
documentation on using the webassembly
javascript side stuff in the browser the
webassembly binary toolkit wabbit
is is here why sometimes the command
line tool you just saw me use
um it's great there's another thing
similar to it called wasimer
um which even has a package manager
called whap him
um wazzy uh the wazzy specs are at
wazzy.dev
uh if you want to build something big uh
rust is
probably the best language to choose at
the moment and
of course there's a link to awesome wasm
languages uh here's a link to the code
and slides so you can hit that qr code
and that will take you out to my github
and you can go get all that stuff
and um worth noting uh i work for
edislab so please go check out our stuff
we've got a discord server and some
community forums and if you want to sign
up for a free class at redis university
we'd love to have you and that's pretty
much all i got
thanks a lot for listening my talk give
me a follow and
are there any questions we have time for
questions